I'm Jacob AI I'm Kaye spany and I'm
Sophia Copa and we're breaking down a
scene from our film
[Music]
Priscilla MH we're back baby be where my
hello hello
hello dod you wait up for me too bless
your little heart in this Scene It shows
um Elvis's been away on uh with with the
Memphis Mafia on they on tour or
shooting a movie they're off doing their
thing and Priscilla's been alone at home
going to high school and um you know
having this life of a student and then
there's a big shift when Elvis comes
home and trying to show that shift in
energy when Elvis comes there's a lot of
excitement there's always music playing
you always have the TV on he always had
people around all the guys around and
kidding laughing and so just to have a
real shift in the energy of that scene
and just to go from her being alone to
when Elvis is there and kind of I think
in any relationship when when you
reconnect with someone there's a kind of
a moment of awkwardness where you're
trying to find your footing and we
wanted to convey that I think this scene
is interesting because um there's a lot
of thought put behind how she was going
to present herself when he comes home
and so you could sort of imagine the
time she took to do her hair and to you
know what color would look best on her
and sort of what what she could do to
sort of catch his attention Stacy uh
costume designer did a great job of
assigning certain looks to certain
moments and I we had spoken about Sophia
was talking on the day about the energy
when the train of us just kind of burst
through that door it's it was Elvis at
his uh Prime like it was he was
absolutely killing it he's back from
Germany he has the girl that that he
wants at home the world still loves him
and he's on fire so it was
he kind of came in like this great white
you know the white jacket is this like
Godly thing up to his color and he was
just completely in his in his element
welcome home baby good to see you baby
oh F what's for
dinner so come
here that's
schol oh it's okay I didn't really talk
to anybody
there grandma and py have been
nice I missed
you been trying to find things to do
with my you got to keep up with your
school work otherwise your father won't
just
stay I know but you sure didn't look
pretty come on let have some NE you know
there was in the book she talks about
that moment where she had been at home
and she was could really couldn't
connect with the other kids at school
and she wanted to like tell him about
that but then she didn't want to be a
drag and burden him as he's just coming
home so she's trying to put on a happy
face so that was what was behind the
scenes yeah just finding that balance of
this sort of heartbreaking moment of
being so excited that Elvis is finally
coming home and get trying to get that
one-on-one time with him and then him
being sort of shuffled into this
Whirlwind and them never having a
private moment together and her always
sort of longing for that and the guys
are always around the mafia is always
around the house is so full but everyone
has learned how to
effortlessly not take his space kind of
what he is doing is what is the sole
Focus so everyone kind of passes and
doesn't really stop him it's just a kiss
and a peck so he can get to his sort of
Throne whereas in in that beat there he
had like chosen to give Priscilla that
time but she kind of wasn't at the stage
yet of learning that you kind of have to
like be like water around him you know
you have to be a to just like get out of
the way when you you know yeah and I
don't know yeah just that Jack's
opposition of those silent moments when
we're on we're focusing on Priscilla's
point of view view um contrasted by this
sort of chaos and storm and energy that
Elvis and his Entourage sort of provide
and I just thought the boys were so
great and coming up with banter the
whole time and it was really it it made
such a difference in terms of me
reacting off of this world and um sort
of um how
disrupted this quiet space that she was
in and uh trying to fit into these
moments yeah and I feel like they all
they have these private jokes and the um
the actors that play the Memphis Mafia
were so great at coming up with stories
and she's trying to fit in but obviously
she wasn't a part of what they were all
a part of so having that
contrast I should miss
you my whole I'll tell you that Ursula
she was always right oh godamn man she
was a big woman was is she pretty God
she had a body like a man no hi
shoulders brother than mine God I was
scared to take my shirt off next to her
the Memphis Mafia was a big part of
Elvis's life they were the guys who were
always around and some of them lived
with them and so Priscilla was always
trying to find moments to be alone with
Elvis when she wasn't there with all the
guys and and um that was always an
element in her her story and and I think
this scene just shows that Elvis is with
all the guys and they're all telling
jokes and having fun and she's trying to
feel a part of it but they're talking
about a time she wasn't there she isn't
really part of it so so that contrast
and and luckily with these great actors
who are all improv comedy guys who could
come up with um with great lines and
it's a kind of corny guy humor that I
don't really know how to write um but
iel like they really embodied how I
imagined that they were and U they they
were a lot of fun in the book Priscilla
talked about him just working with
Ursula Andrews and how he was always
working with these starlets and you know
how that made her how made her feel and
trying to be cool with it but still uh
insecure one of the things that was
really important to her was um the love
between them too and um us trying to
focus on the highs and lows and we
wanted it to feel really human and like
you were saying um didn't want it to
feel one note it wanted it to feel like
a roller coaster like a lot of
relationships can be especially first
loves yeah and how she described it yeah
I think like you said she's trying to
sort of play it cool and not obviously
she has so much fear and and has so many
questions about what goes on when she's
not around but also is trying to tow a
line and uh sort of be sensitive in the
moment and not be too much but also what
was she like was she pretty you know
what was going on and to try to sort of
pick try to pick things up all the the
little details and take in the cues and
also when we um settle in on her and her
just trying to take in the surrounding
conversations and her feeling like like
I'm not exactly sure what my place is in
this moment and her just trying to
navigate that he's from the south at a
uh from a time period that's completely
different to how it is now and he's sort
of was um bought up on like a
traditional gender roles and um it's
pretty consistent throughout uh his
career in interviews and in writing that
he liked um you know his mom his mom was
a stay-at-home mom and like you know the
woman playing the role of the woman
yeah so it was it was pretty pretty
clear in the text which I think was true
for I would say like a majority of
people from the South in that time
period she only had eyes for you no way
man with that John Derek just luring
around with him be
eyes SNES
like Shadow I tell you man I gu stand
that
guy
God
God the whole story I really wanted to
be through her point of view and her
eyes and how she felt so we always try
to connect it to her and her emotional
experience and and in that scene um in
the editing when we were kind of trying
to see how long we could stay on her and
and there's a shift in her face where
she's like trying to go along with it
and then you see her kind of be more
internal and she's not connecting and so
much of that scene is about her trying
to connect and not really knowing how to
and um and I think Kay's so able to
convey so much just on her face you can
really feel what she's feeling um in
such a subtle way thank you you know
Sophia is sort of a master at um telling
so much with with um very little words
you know and I think those are the
moments that you you know your heart
breaks for someone or you feel like
you're you're with them um just those
internal ups and downs and and so yeah I
I I think that's exactly want I wanted
to portray in that moment and um her
just
um uh letting the reality of what this
life is like and sort of um balancing
out what she hopes this moment would be
but actually what what is usually
like